you guys are very wealthy do you guys
like to like flaunt your wealth to your
viewers yeah all the time all the
[ __ ] time dude actually no what no
maybe you could
because how would we do that
you just like make remarks I mean you
guys kind of casually do it with like
your hobbies and what you do around
anyways that like people are like okay
so they
they have money to go do those things I
wish I could do that yeah like golfing
like the Cabo thing like the last time I
was on this on this on this fine podcast
Noelle shame me that I've never been to
Kabul before you go you guys go left and
right twice you're this year you were
your C's was your your wedding was
overseas it was you're gone every
weekend I don't know how you do anything
in your life because I'll look at your
Instagram go through you're gone all the
time I've I've had I've had two trips in
the last like four months I just can't
believe that I just refuse to believe
that and they were both Austin
so many tropical no stories I've seen
and stuff you don't even know I've seen
it with my own eyes what do you say is
it gone a lot yeah of course I don't
leave that much all the time you know
what you probably don't think you you
probably have it's just like a mental
shift of like maybe like going to see
Grandma now to you is it going to like
Cabo yeah whatever so you're just like I
mean I guess I am going on a trip in a
few weeks Sacramento California
I get why you would think that Capital
yes no is that the capital of yeah is
that California yeah in a sec town maybe
this weekend
see me in Columbus
Ohio I saw the set not very good
it's not true it was very good I
actually don't want to go on record
saying that that's actually Fair it was
actually very good thanks yeah yeah no
it's just Hunter didn't have insulin so
he couldn't it's true I did have a
diabetic stroke while I was like
watching it so he actually was funny
because I was the owner making noise in
the club but it was just me actually
doing
this whole time wow they really like me
they like it they like my scent
so there's a [ __ ] insulin
help this man
God damn my joke's murder dude I'm
killing up here
now I did have actually it's funny you
say that the last set in Austin I had a
weird ass opening I tried to like roast
the City of Austin a little bit like
that was a crap huh they didn't mind it
no no I don't think you were you were
there for that one I should have been
the last one that you've been to Austin
yeah you were there too weren't you were
there yeah no no because of the five
shows I don't think you saw the very
last one on Sunday oh so you're saying
while you were there in Austin the last
one yeah yeah I think it was Saturday
one yeah no yeah Saturday was good uh
but yeah that Sunday I like
kind of like made some jokes about
Austin and then the crowd just was like
kind of aggro I'm like all right let me
just dial it back and then it ended up
being fine what'd you say uh I just came
out and I was like you guys are like
[ __ ] weird I suck no it's kind of the
same thing of like oh you think you guys
are like I think you did that on
Saturday too a little bit this one was
different because so what I'll do
through the weekend is like as I feel
like I start to figure out the town I'll
actually give my thoughts in real time
so by the last Sunday I was like
you guys are [ __ ] strange like a lot
of you are just like tech people that
moved here like during the pandemic and
you came and like you [ __ ] all the
housing prices and I just kind of like
went on this rant and then the security
guard was in the back like
at the end of the show he was like dude
he [ __ ] nailed it but I think
everyone else I think what it was is
that not a majority of the people in the
crowd were actually from Austin so they
didn't feel like it was about them so
they're kind of looking around the room
like oh I wonder if anyone from Austin
gets it pretty brave of you thanks dude
yeah I'm standing up for free speech up
there I think so yeah I'm doing my civic
duty literally keeping the Constitution
alive so yeah yeah stand up is a Heroes
game guys yeah
I think I've heard somebody say that oh
yeah because that stand-up comedians or
comedians or modern day philosophers
they are yeah they're going to make a
bunch of little dick statues about us
kind of like they did in Europe for all
the all their guys
I've just been going on Twitter a lot
yeah that's how I'm keeping Free Speech
alive oh right it's been cruising elon's
Twitter yeah profile
he's looking through his replies are you
a big Elon fan
no
okay
no I think that his use of Twitter right
now is just obscene and also kind of
entertaining it's a little bit it's
hilarious you see the speaking of
diabetes you saw the [ __ ] insulin
Tweet someone made a parody of a like an
insulin producer and was like we're now
giving insulin for free and then they
had to they lost like other ton of like
their stock tanks 20 billion dollars in
market caps
oh that's right this is this is why I
think like it wasn't the tweet I mean it
must have been but like what do you
think the crossover is between people
that read that follows Eli Lilly on
Twitter yeah and knows how to use a
stock exchange I don't think it's
necessarily that I I wonder how much of
it is they know that like journalists
will hop on that yeah and be like oh my
God and then like the whole verify it's
just like it's a trickle-down effect of
like everything that's going on but it
happened like instantly oh really so
like as soon as the Tweet went the stock
just dropped basically as soon as it
started going viral the stock just like
[ __ ] tanked so like people are on
there laying like oh I gotta drop like
the people that would fall for that
tweet sorry that's what I meant what
what what's like the Venn diagram of
people that would fall for a fake parody
account Twee like that 99 also Twitter
users yeah what's your favorite stock
yeah do you know what my favorite stock
is I like to I like to think of the
viable stock market I would probably go
into Google
chicken stock chicken stock Maybe
I like a nice chicken
how is that is that Google
I bet it's green so what's up would have
been making money this week yep I think
that's how it works
just picture your dad hearing like
what's your favorite type of stock and
he's like well it ain't it ain't short
barrel stock cause I tell you what I am
afraid of a goddamn aren't you Gus this
is the kind of quality you can see live
on the Noel Miller tour that will never
actually end it's been going on for
three years now so you're probably
wondering you know what's funny is you
always say like gotta get them while
they're out sold out I'm like you're
definitely coming back
uh uh let's let's argue there let's
argue there going back to where
[ __ ] anything I've seen you go back
here like I remember like seeing you
were playing like a no-name town in
Nebraska I'm like why why are you going
back there for
because you're hit you're hitting every
other you're I think you're trying to
hit every town in America uh yeah is
that the point of that this will never
enter no
um it's my agents being like weirdly
there's a resonance here in butt [ __ ]
Nebraska but what it really is is those
towns like hit in the middle of like a
bunch of different areas I see yeah it
would be funny to call a tour I'm coming
back eventually yeah yeah like
this is gonna sell out this is gonna
sell out because of fomo but I'm gonna
be back so if you have to work like if
he like bills are tight unlike for me
take time I'm gonna be back like I will
tour again you're gonna hear this oh no
I'll tour again but there are definitely
towns where I'm like I'm never going
back what's your least favorite place
you've played I'm actually curious
um Syracuse New York I was just there
I'll never go back there why why
everything about it kiss my ass even
like the people and everything
are like the response from the crowd or
whatever it's just I just odd behavior
from those from those crowds they're
just [ __ ] like I I don't know what
world some of those people are in I
don't want to generalize but Syracuse
for sure sure I'll I'll never go back so
yeah get them while they're hot
noelmillerlive.com definitely not coming
back